[Music]
bead with
2x
voodoo
[Music]
voodoo bass pro Menwoorupe
voodoo Tomorrow I was going to call it the intended Dale Ramen amare cd Ramen Miraku
2007  It has been open
since the year, so it will be the first one for my father now, so I expressed it in the form of this local silicon benoa salt ramen
and opened it so that everyone in Japan can eat it
[Music]
nsg  Instant Ramen begin Edition Takea ore
First of all, the work to make the essential soup is to carefully extract the soup stock of Rishiri kelp
and the soup containing various other kinds of after-animals and
the longest one for 15 hours.
Combine the finished soup into one and let it rest for a while.
The scent of the roasted soup and the soup are combined
to create the perfect balance of sweetness and saltiness.
[Music]
Christie's 4 s split winpy  Poka Marg Sway
Definitely uses that local silicon part abundantly to make the soup stock, so the inner ramen
is delicious are you
doing Please eat
Bob arasara
[music]
Suzu work worm
anda came to do the Paifa moderno legends
keep our  Surf pup the blue
cure
Probably 71 years ago, it was severe.
Atmospheric ramen is called the original Toyama Black.
A
true Doon Naa is a Chinese noodle bar.
Toyama Black is a local.  People don't say so much
Press bob Old man's day bag Instant noodles Subwoofer is also light and dark
Blue Big Masami-san
Lord Di dies 1 berth is a porter 4 me for needs
rbo  The
surrounding area was also a burnt field. At that time, I didn't have much to eat,
but
the founder was wondering if there was anything like a side dish of rice.
First of all, the color of the feathers is really black.  I think
this is the color of the thing Nya 9 car height is not attached
There are 5 kinds of soy sauce with plainness and secret ones
, so I think it happened to be black
hd 1 Char siu arm bar kramen half tiger space Toyama
[Music]
Boobare Osaka
It is very rare at that time  I think it's a visual ramen.
After all, the first impression is important.
My characteristic of Toyama Black is that it looks dark and
salty, but it's actually very mild.
Basically, it's
all from 1 to 10.  0 Noodle King Soup and the power of char siu are all this can
you do
Toyama Black
is not what I invented, but it
is said that the drug in the head made it famous in Japan.  I think it's the most important with it
Hahahahan
Tag ah ah
ah ah ah
wh
Black camp type
four 4 cente Rose whip broker ways to do
over Honmiya s in japan a
do do s 5 e Harlem Fugu Andu pou dou  dou
Green Ruler Meat words
p Star g you do Rose
Princess ben & protege desperate Howsy Meeting
Rover sway bar funny pictures Already Pea Pober
Castel dao
[Music]
voodoo Weekly
voodoo
g love cover ntn Lone
Member Garth barbie Download Peace Pastry
[Music]
Run Now  Until then, the person
who pushes the noodles
says that it
's a noodle that eats the sun. Sauce Cat's chanko nabe is eaten and everyone is quite worried
.
The name is to go to the living materials.
The shop is located in the Tokyo Metropolitan Police Department. The
shop sells chanko nabe as a grade item.
Now I'm stroking
a very well-balanced pork with fruits and vegetables
.
Bach
Tsushin Kazuhisa
has one perspective to eat and eat
[Music]
Sumo Wrestling Japan is what I call
Oshio.
About 10 chankos, even a lot of language bowls go to the back
I entered the smoker at 15 and how many were active until the 3rd division 4 The
dream is the number 3 in
Sekiwake I thought about opening a store  After all, this deliciousness
is delicious. I asked everyone to know about the delicious foods of the United States, such as hospitals, etc. I
opened it for free
.
I've been instructed to do various kinds of things, but I
'm not tired of it,
so I still love to blow and chanpon
ani
Basically, I love to eat
me